all right Andreas and Noah yeah where
are you guys from Virginia you grew up
in L.A yeah I'm from right here in L.A
I'm from Cleveland Cleveland
how long you been here
been here about 15 years
you like L.A love it
very different from Cleveland OH
you're right about that definitely yeah
I've been a lot of other places but uh I
always end up coming back to LA uh
stayed in Tennessee uh in uh Knoxville
uh Vegas for a little bit but uh
yeah
they have everything right here all in
one spot and the the whole Trail is
different too so yeah there's nothing
like Figueroa Street yeah
tourist attraction
you should be
I think somehow they should move it
closer to the sofa though but I mean
yeah I think the police
have decided that Figueroa Street is the
spot where they can do that it's uh it's
like mapped out already yeah it's like
zoned for it if a girl goes to another
street she gets busted right away with
him yeah maybe Western they can do it
that's funny well Western's the new one
it's like the like they're basically
like the upcoming fig
because you know base basically it's
like you have different
zones Century Imperial you got fig I
learned not that long ago that a lot of
the hotels on Century kind of by the
airport
are full of girls doing business
there used to be like the Fig uh back in
yeah in the 1998 look around right there
yeah you can't walk the street yeah
it's about money people flying and and
they right off the plane they're
checking in and then they're booking you
know what I mean it's convenience you
know you get off the airport you don't
have to go too far you get your little
car you get your little hooker you know
I mean that's you know that's that's
what people that's what people do over
here humans are humans
yeah yeah somebody's got to service the
community
Keeps The Crazies off the street I think
yeah yeah or it keeps traffic backed up
yeah sometimes
so you guys are friends yeah how long
you guys known each other
uh probably like uh like seven ten years
probably something like that yeah you
guys have jobs
uh yeah I do mobile web developing and
website and stuff like that yeah I'm uh
specialist tech tech specialist they
like computer stuff so so you guys
frequent Figaroa Street
something just pulls us pulls me back
like constantly just to see what you
know what came out
what's uh however you guys could have
girlfriends
like like a normal relationship
oh no yeah yeah I'm at the Norman issue
but sometimes like uh
maybe I I have trouble finding the girl
who's like freakish enough to like do
some of the stuff that you know I like
to do so that's what I ended up making
one go back to to Vegas stuff like that
to just
pay some dirty [__] to do it or whatever
like that you know I mean and sometimes
the stuff that I want you gotta pay for
so
you know you're just not gonna be doing
that type of stuff without
you know paying somebody to do it
I'm afraid to ask what is that you know
it's just a you know
a variety of things you know just like
you know it depends on how you uh
how you wanna how you want it handled or
you know how much attention you wanted
you know wanted to spend on you know
find a girl to do whatever you want down
there right well I mean usually for a
certain price you know you know it's not
going to be like no questions asked no
like attitude oh you can't be like that
you gotta like this and oh it's uh what
are you doing it like that no you don't
get none of that right or the actual
courting part of courting the girl for
for quite an extended period of time and
then not getting the the results that
you're with because you know like like
in the end you're trying to hook up with
her and stuff like that or a certain way
you know what I mean and
if I had to spend all this time and
money uh investing into uh her and then
it doesn't work out you're just like
well [__] I could have just went big and
just paid some [__] you know what I
mean like a certain amount of money and
you wouldn't have had all that you know
you wouldn't have to like
you know feel like a sucker or I feel
like gum just because you're trying to
do the right thing and be good and and
you know you know play the role and then
next thing you know they're just you
know
oh that could be just bypass you can go
right past go and collect you know
versus going fig and
um they got what they wanted I got what
I wanted everybody walks away a happy
camper you know what I mean and it's uh
it's been said a million times that
you're not paying the girl to to come to
your place you or get together with you
you're paying her to leave that part
right that partner to keep her mouth
closed too
yeah and she's getting paid just for
privacy you know like it's like not
everybody needs to know the drama and
what's going on it's like sometimes I
find myself like I got a phone call hey
and I'm not gonna turn nothing down so
it's like I get a phone call usually
it's like I'm there you know I'm you
ain't got to tell me more than once like
that you want to do something like it
doesn't matter like I'm gonna show up
you know so it's like I found myself
like I couldn't stop you know like no
matter how many calls I got I was still
showing up or still you know being a
part of the action and sometimes it gets
a little demanding
you know yeah sometimes
um like for me uh one of the things uh I
like to do is I like to perform on cam
in front of strangers so uh webcaming uh
uh my my last look so lady she wasn't
into that so but sometimes I would do
that and just perform online
uh but not even for money for or for
anything just as an exhibitionist or
whatever
[Laughter]
and uh
sometimes I have to go to Fig to [__]
uh
get your girls to do it or something
like that and yeah
yeah
you guys will
frequent some of the same girls more
than once you have regulars
um I have
two or three that probably I I would
frequent like uh did I go back to but
some of them are just like uh a one-time
thing and the the way you cycle so many
times on Facebook
new girls out there all the time so it's
uh sometimes it's hard to hold on if you
have a regular
we started noticing uh patterns like we
we'd have certain uh
certain people we we meet or we you know
talk to and then and then they cycle
like you know a couple months later
you would have them and then and then
and then they switch back and then it's
like we're like what's going on here
like are they all like I share the same
girl sometimes
um yeah yeah it's like they've become
friends and something I thought it was a
completely different girl because she
came back bald when I once I got her oh
went through a midlife crisis huh yeah
if you came back bald and uh she had no
hair and I was like whoa this new chick
oh no no it's not a new chick it's just
the girls it's me it's me
I don't know what what day I went
through or what happened yeah you guys
must have some crazy stories of some of
your exploits down there
I remember one time uh I had yeah this
one I just came from Tennessee and I
came down and uh
I was chilling with uh where my brother
and uh
I was uh I I wasn't uh comfortable going
out on feet quite yet so I was doing
like the escort thing and uh that time I
had a lot of money because I had just
finished doing this big job and um
they uh I was running through the escort
and you know I ordered a white girl with
green eyes they deliver her I wanted a a
black girl with big booty uh they'd send
her you know by the end of the week they
kind of knew me and stuff like that so
uh
uh I think that at that time uh that
movie A Night in Paris had just came out
so I wanted a girl to look like Paris
Hilton they come in just a girl for you
uh
they they brought her over and uh
she was she started she came in she goes
it's
four hundred dollars to take my shirt
off another 200 if you want a hand job
another 300 if you want to hit and I was
like whoa whoa whoa like he barely just
took off your shirt and gave me a hand
job I'm sorry like 1400 bucks like I
ain't spending that much money on you
you don't mean that lately and she goes
I got you to get high and she goes yeah
and she does crystal so we started
towards the pipe in uh I tell her you
know I want to play a game that
sometimes plays like a copycat she goes
what's that I'll go we're gonna put on a
movie and whatever they do in the movie
me and you are going to try and reenact
in person yeah uh and uh
yeah so we started doing that so I put
it on like anal assassins and assault
that ass and I've never done that before
part two or whatever
and uh at that time sometimes I was
smoking cocaine too so I took a hit of
cocaine in it and sometimes you take one
too big and
you get paranoid so I took I took a real
good one and I was like yo you got to
leave and she goes okay but you owe me
some money go how much I could try me
2700 bucks
and I was like oh the hell no I was like
here here's here's 500. we've been
getting high all night you know what I
mean like lately uh she goes no no you
owe me this money goes towards the
restroom
she goes towards the restroom and she's
getting dressed but you know this is my
early uh chicken days or whatever like
that so I didn't know that all these
most of these girls have drivers that
are that accompany them so uh Brothers
yeah she she popped over her brother she
popped out the restroom and popped out
uh uh uh opened the door to the hallway
and then came in this big ass dude I
don't know if you're actually resting
but looking like Lex Luger
and he came in and he's like we got a
problem here and I was like what who the
[__] are you but he was so big I tried
to rush him but uh uh
he just put one hand on my chest one on
my back actually squished me and threw
me across the room dude and I went and
flew and landed on the table and my dope
went flying everywhere I just ran to
where I had my money and I threw the
rest of the money at him and told him
get the hell the hell out of here
and yeah that's
that'll happen down there right yeah how
often you guys go down there
um every time I try to leave something
keeps pulling me back
I probably like like a couple times a
week how many times like like two three
times a week at least you think it's
expensive no yeah sometimes you just go
to just it's just a look
yeah just to see what's going on I mean
you know it's not really like the whole
like
it's like you just can't believe what
you see sometimes it's very uh
it's very in captivating yeah it's
pretty incredible what goes on down
there on a nightly basis
there's nowhere you see anywhere like
that like and the Hub is like 65th like
it's like that's where it's all like
stems from
but it's like you'd be surprised who you
like you just be like you're down what
are you doing here like you know like
and and they're just like ready for
battle you know like fully like capable
or whatever and it's just it's like it's
pretty insane yeah sometimes you'll find
the the like like the most amazing girl
and she's over here doing [__] for 60
bucks or something like that you know
what I mean come on down huh I mean like
that I used to be Captain Save A house
like we gotta get you out of here we
gotta clean you up we gotta do something
right like and then now it's like dude
let them do what they're doing okay yeah
because is there a temptation to try to
straighten out some of these girls at
first through I was like dude I'd be
like oh my God we gotta save your life I
like every time like and I was just like
real naive like that to think that you
know I can make a difference or whatever
I'm trying to do they're gonna play you
before you help yeah but every time they
just you know it ends up being some I'm
spinning my wheels I'm the one that I
need and saving you know like so it's
like I I made peace with that stuff
yeah it kind of sucks but sometimes some
of the products they really don't want
to save me it's just uh the cycle that
they're in but they love it no matter
how many things I've tried to help them
break that cycle uh right back it's just
they'll be doing the same [__] the next
week so like
and I gotta live my life so I got to go
work or do whatever like that so you
can't be
holding their hand the whole time you
know what I mean
as soon as you let go they're back on
the stroll so you know they only pop up
when they need some
drugs are part of your life now
um yeah
um and it started off with the with when
I was uh first picking up dates
sometimes it was cheaper to find the
ones that get high a little bit or
something like that and then like oh you
should try it you know what I mean and
yeah there's all kind of games that are
played with that one
you know because then it's like you know
it's a little cheaper in one aspect but
then it's like next thing you know
they're helping you look for your
helping you look for it and whatnot you
know yeah or just some some type of oh
what happened oh I don't know I'll be
like I didn't see nothing uh oh man we
smoked all over whatever I don't like
this one go get another one that seems
to be the most popular drug down there
well there's new trends it should be
cocaine a lot better back in the early
2000s I remember it was cocaine was like
the crack that it
was a crack was pretty much like like
the crystal is now it was more like yeah
they just seem the most like
like insanely beautiful
wonderful looking
woman like smoking Sherm and all kinds
of Hardcore stuff like you wouldn't even
expect to see or even know about it's
like wow
DMT
they're just getting plastered like and
like nothing like functioning like oh
driving like like it's not even
affecting them like their tolerances are
so like you know adapt to it it's like
you know I'm like whoa yeah you guys are
way over my head like they just need to
do a whole bunch just to be normal just
to you know function let alone like if
they really want to turn up and get
higher and some of the girls I was
telling them the other day I was like
man I think you must have uh super
powers because like I hear in the news
about somebody doing Fentanyl and they
do like a little a little [__] or
something like that and they're they're
dead but this [__] is like like
steadily smoking grams of it every day
and [__] like I'm like are you inhaling
that [__] you must have like real
superpowers or something something in
your DNA yeah the body's built about
resistance yeah they take a hit and blow
it in the room the cat is like overdose
and then they're still like like nothing
like it's like what's going on like how
much can you really ingest to that [__]
like yeah before it takes it's like it
doesn't have no effect or I would think
they'd be blowing it out dude I remember
one time um I was smoking cocaine and uh
um the homegirl wanted to uh try some of
the [__] that I was smoking I was like
nah you ain't ready for this and she's
like oh come on and then um
she took a hit and I started uh [__]
her or whatever like that and [__] um
she started having a seizure on me so I
I was like oh [__] I was like I know my
dick's good but it's not that good like
what the [__] I I was like I I was like
what do you do like I remember that they
said supposed to put some down there
their mouth so they don't swallow their
own tongue or something like that the
only spoon I had was the one that I was
cooking dope on it still had dope on one
side and it was black on the other and I
grabbed that spoon and I shoved it right
down her mouth and then she's like
and then when she came to she just
looked at me like a deer with the
headlights screamed
ran out the motel room butt naked I I
tried catching her I seen the police
downstairs I said [__] that I just
closed the door and just have to uh take
care of myself
and call it a day but yeah I remember
that day yep
that girl she later like hung herself a
couple months later but yes really yeah
all right it's sad when you see the the
whole like you know they they're not
themselves and they're not happy either
you know go through this like Street
walking phase where it's like you know
you see the decline the plummet and it's
like hey and then you're like
you know it's like yeah that's sad you
know like that's really sad that's
messed up
because usually once they go like that
they do they're not coming back it's
like knock knock no one's home you know
if you knew the background story of why
they're down there it becomes a really
sad situation yes
yeah it goes all the way back to like
you know the childhood I'm in hurt I
mean sat there and played Dr Phil to the
point where it's like I I know now like
the symptoms and the mechanisms and the
triggers for that and yeah you just try
to pay Dr Phillip you know
[Laughter]
yeah but it's like you know it's
you know there's no uh it's inevitable
is it as much as you would think you
want to like do something to prevent it
it's still going to happen yeah you know
so it's like you think prostitution
should be legalized
it's like not it's not well
it's kind of weird because like like if
you pay somebody to have sex supposedly
it's a crime but if you pay somebody to
have sex in front of a camera now it's
okay and it's legal like if they're
doing adult films now because there's a
camera there and it's they're acting or
something like that now it's legal where
um I I think they should
um it's probably gonna be a little more
regulated or something like that but um
yeah I I think it probably should it's
one of the oldest professions there is
so it's never going to change it's going
to be that like that and if they let it
be legal that means they're going to be
taxing it and if they don't then that
means they're going to be collected
anyway so either way it goes and that
that's all the way back on the Stone Age
[__] you know just like uh on fig where
that that one street just seems that
it's just allowed because the girls are
out there with their outfits on and like
just so brazing like that
I feel that it's just the right person
has to get the envelope and if they
don't receive their envelope when that's
when they start tripping you know like
so maybe just that little strip is
allowed and
somebody got a big enough envelope then
maybe uh they would allow it throughout
the state or the county or whatnot like
that yeah
I understand that
it's a dangerous thing man
it's real dangerous thing you're dealing
with that's why you know
who knows but it's like yeah that's
probably the main reason is that it's
probably double a sore too like you're
saying maybe it is best to keep it
contained on one street
so where if you wanted you know if you
got my money honey then we got your
disease you'll get what you want right
there have you guys picked up any
diseases
um yeah but surprisingly not from a
working girl from a actual lady
or one day you tell me like oh I'm going
to Planned Parenthood I'm getting tested
I think you should go to Whitby and I
was a man in a monogamous relationship
for about like 13 months and yeah
and then I go and I got two things and
I've never had anything throughout my
entire life and I was like well [__] you
and monogamy
we're using condoms all the time when
you're down there uh yes yes with the
with work girls yeah
yeah
probably uh you probably sleep better at
night if you do yeah
yeah I only take it off when I'm doing
facials or something like that yeah
yeah
[Music]
I think it's only been about like three
or four girls that have not used
protection with really yep
you're cold
[Laughter]
ah never mind that yeah
whatever you say is the most interesting
thing you've learned from your time on
Figaro Street
what have you learned about women
actually usually if they uh
if they if they like you they're gonna
act like it if they don't they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna lie to you
yeah if you know it just depends like
you know they're really straightforward
like that yeah and I found it just best
uh when you're in a transactional phase
just be upfront on what you're looking
for and what you need and and
what's the required dollar amount
because if you just leave it like in a
gray area and then you try and rush it
then at the end try and charge you more
or something like that so you deal with
pimps sometimes yeah yeah but so it's
best just some of y'all look this is
what I want to do this is it I got this
much cash yeah you know what I mean I
don't want somebody doing something they
don't want to do anyway you know what I
mean like uh but
yeah
does just be a friend
be yourself yeah
all right Andreas Noah thank you so much
for
sharing your experiences on fig all
right and I wish you guys lots of luck
all right I'll just have somebody have a
fun weekend